so you're fighting uh Edwin de los
Santos yes um I don't know who the hell
this guy is so I'm assuming that you're
going to beat the living out of
this guy yeah n but he's he's a good
fighter I'm going to put it out there
and say U I watched him uh he got good
boxing skills um you got to respect your
opponent at all times man no no he's a
good fighter though no what I'm saying
but you have to like I feel like
sometimes we see our like boxers popping
in press conferences and I'm like
yo man like this guy's still
professional there's a reason why he's
fighting so this guy's good what I'm
saying is you just got to be aware of
who you're in the ring with sometimes
and being aware of that you don't want
to sleep on nobody uh sleeping on that
dude would be like the wrong move for me
to make so um this dude is a great boxer
puncher and um you could tell that he's
hungry and he's going to come to win so
uh for sure I I respect him as a a
fighter but he's just going against the
best he's going against the best and uh
I'm sure all the money in Vegas is on
you so yeah for sure yeah